foreign
Carter joins us in Richmond Virginia up
next Carter welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me how are you
guys we're doing great what's going on
with you
um so I am 19.
um I graduated high school last year I'm
not planning to go to college and this
year I'll plan to make about 40 000 with
my job I'm in right now I make about 30
000 in uh doing Contracting and about
ten thousand on the side hustle uh do
you mind Connor I just wanna I wanna
brag on you uh because that's really
good money for a 19 year old what kind
of Contracting are you doing
uh we do like house remodels editions
right so you went straight out of high
school into that huh
pretty much yep you enjoy it
oh I do yeah it's great yeah go make a
lot of money aren't you yeah we do all
right sorry I selfishly took over the
call that's great I'm sending a little
subtle message to parents Across America
there go ahead Sir with your question
um I'm just wondering um with with that
experience and getting there um I would
really like to buy and uh flip a house
and have it for myself here but I'm just
wondering um is it too soon for me to
uh be able to buy them again and be able
to get approved for a loan or do I need
to wait um if so how long I'm trying to
get married in probably about three
years or so uh two or three years so I'm
not sure if I should wait till after
that to buy a house but I'd love to buy
a house and be able to fix it up um and
then be able to get married and move and
do it well I love your drive I love that
you have these kinds of goals at 19
years old and I think you're going to
get there so how much money do you have
currently saved
uh really not much I just had to buy a
car with cash so that kind of took away
oh boy the savings I had for that
um so I'm just now kind of starting to
get back and trying to save a lot for
that um how much I I'm from the I'm from
Virginia and I lived in Richmond for a
year so I'm just curious how big of a
house and how much are you thinking
um I'm not not big probably
um a thousand to two thousand at the
very most um in the area I'm at there
are plenty for sale right now around
that for about 200 to 300 000 in a great
area
um I work for my parents right now and
I'm looking kind of in the area where
we're at and
um yeah so probably probably about 200
000 about I don't know 1200 square feet
yeah well I I think you're you're on to
something here having much more focused
goals and that's what we teach when it
comes to goal settings we want it to be
specific measurable in writing yours and
you're doing that by saying three years
from now I want to purchase a 250 000
house how much do I need to be saving to
be able to put down to qualify for the
loan and we have very specific
parameters that I think there's a lot of
wisdom to it and that is don't do
anything but a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage where the payment is no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
and what's great is that helps dictate
how much down payment you need to have
so for some people that might be 50 for
some it might be 20 for some it might be
ten percent
but I think a guy as young as you who's
that already so successful I would aim
for 20 on a 200 000 house at least and
uh your income is going to go up over
the next three years am I right
yeah yeah I think the cap is with my
current employers about 50 000 a year
what's the cap about five houses
uh he just my boss told me that um with
uh the work and stuff I can't make more
than uh 25 an hour interesting okay well
I mean that may be true I mean that you
know he that he gets to decide that
that's the free market but you're not
capped you may be capped in that job but
you are not cap my friend you know that
yeah
so I so that's that's why I'm trying to
pick up these side hustles here doing
handyman and other things to be able to
make up that extra you know 10 20 a year
yes sir you keep that up for another
three years I would wait until you're
married if that's on the horizon in the
next three years because you need that
time to save up anyways
okay and so I would jump onto
ramseysolutions.com you can use our
mortgage calculator and that will help
dictate exactly what your down payment
goal is so you have something to aim for
over the next three years and that will
also fuel you in your side jobs and your
work you're doing every day and uh you
know with putting a ring on and getting
married what an exciting time for you
mm-hmm yeah
you feel good about this Carter I think
so I think so and one one other
clarifying question
um
you know if uh if I need to have
um you know you're saying 20 percent
um down of the total house or 20 of my
income that would be of the purchase
price of the home
okay okay of your income will be 25 of
your take-home pay so you're after after
you pay Uncle Sam uh whatever's left of
that 25 should be allocated to that
mortgage payment at the most too and so
if that payment is looking like 35 40
you don't have enough margin to do other
things like invest and save up for a car
and have fun and go on vacation unless I
forget Carter you want to fix this thing
up so you're going to buy something
that's that's got more value once you
put your Blood Sweat and Tears into the
house so George is absolutely right
waiting longer is okay because you're
always going to be able to get something
like that number one number two you're
not married yet that's off in the
distance and you can save up easily the
Forty thousand on a two hundred thousand
dollar that gives you your 20 you need
to save up more in my opinion because
that gives you the cash that you need to
come in and fix it up and you knowing
what the prices are of materials you
doing a lot of the work yourself or
you've probably got some buddies who are
Tradesmen who may be special as they
come in I mean I know how this works so
you need some extra cash to get the
house where you want it so that when
your new wife comes in
you carry Across the Threshold he
probably doesn't even know what that is
threshold you know it's a it's a much
better house so patience is the play
here you know
yeah and with the current market though
that things are kind of
not stale I guess yet but you don't
think you don't think I should go now
but I should wait no no you don't have
the money now George just walked you
through that and never never try to time
the market because truthfully we don't
know what it's going to do and so I'd
much rather have this piece under my
control and go when I can financially
afford this to where it's a blessing and
not a curse that's when I'm ready to buy
a house regardless of what the market is
doing
and that's a very freeing feeling
because you're not stressed thinking
about what's going to happen with the
market six months from now what if I got
a bad deal because six months later it
went down I could have got a better deal
man with your skill set you're gonna
find a deal on a fixer upper deal passed
on that's you're gonna turn that thing
into a Butte in no time oh look at that
I love it George I love when you go all
Northern on us that's a beaut that's a
beaut Clark uh I'm bada bing bada boom
he's got a house in no time and Carter I
love I love the energy Ken I love young
people yeah who have this level of
maturity and drive I was trying to stay
out of the way and let you help the
young man but I just want to brag on him
and again paint another picture for
American parents and kids for 40 or 50
years we've been shoved a marketing
message from culture coming from the
federal and state governments and higher
ed has been shoving a message down our
throats that college is the only way to
success and you got kids like Carter who
doesn't want to darken the door of
college he doesn't need to go to college
and thankfully he didn't go to college
what did he do he went to work and he's
good at it and he's 19 and he's calling
us he just paid cash for a car and I
would say the majority of his 19 year
old friends in that Richmond Virginia
area have gone to school and they're
borrowing money to get a degree they
can't use and don't want to use
but here's an alternative a Tradesman at
19. I'm tired of people looking down
their nose at the trades and parents
being embarrassed to say my kid didn't
go to college he went to work and that's
a good thing yeah I love this let's skip
the name brand school to get the
Philosophy degree so that a parents can
feel good about themselves and yet the
kid has no job opportunity at the end of
that none they're strapped with student
loan debts and going wait you guys
screwed me over you lied and we've got
to stop this and it starts with the
parents you're so right Ken